une collection de lampes berger
d'appareils photos de timbres ou bien
encore de cendriers un aperçu des
trésors que l'on pouvait dénicher lors
de la bourse des multi collections de
ville preuve l'association est née il y
a trente ans et nous avions pris
l'habitude de faire une réunion annuelle
des collectionneurs de façon à les
réunir dans un lieu tranquille
beaucoup plus serein qu'une brocante
normal l'ambiance y est sereine mais
aussi fraternelle et conviviale
car ici se retrouve des passionnés c'est
le cas de gabriel amoureux de la
photographie qui expose une infime
partie de sa collection d'appareils
photo j'ai commencé à collectionner pour
faire voir pour faire voir comment la
photo avait s'était développée après
avec quel matériel on avait fait au
petit à petit dans les années comment ça
avait marché comme avait une
fonctionnaire alors les premiers
appareils photo cd après davaï photo ap
lac automatiquement action à pareille
sabres à quelques stands de la halle un
philatéliste collectionne les timbres
depuis plusieurs années à force de
trouvailles
ils se retrouvent souvent avec des lots
en double qui leur vend ainsi lors des
salons ou brocante
je prépare soit en lots comme la de
différents pays
soit des lettres aussi des vieux papiers
on vient quand même pour essayer de
faire un peu d'affaires comme l'os à
travers l'année dernière ça avait été
encore plus prolifique mais là c'est pas
mal marché
la bourse multicollection a réuni pour
cette édition 2010 est une cinquantaine
de curieux